[Music]
welcome back to signs click today the
Doppler effect let's take two
individuals we'll call them a and B a
begins to shout while shouting he
produces a wave which propagates through
the air with a certain frequency if the
frequency is high the sound will be
high-pitched if the frequency is low the
sound will be low-pitched be situated at
a distance from a hears the sound as he
is receiving the sound waves with the
same frequency now let's take a look at
what happens if a gets closer to B we
see that the waves in front of a gets
squashed this implies that their
frequency increases as the distance
between two waves grows smaller on the
other side the waves get stretched as
such their frequency decreases as the
distance between two waves grows larger
since the frequency on the right has
increased B will hear more high-pitched
sound waves and if B were to be on the
other side and he would hear more
low-pitched sound waves since the
frequency has decreased on this side
this is what we call the Doppler effect
to sum up if an object emits a sound
wave with a certain frequency and it is
moving towards the receiver then the
receiver will detect the wave with a
higher frequency
inversely if the emitter moves away from
the receiver then the receiver will
detect the wave with a lower frequency a
good example of the Doppler effect is
the movement of a car as the car gets
closer to us we hear a higher pitched
sound while the sound that produces
becomes progressively lower post when it
crosses us and moves further away
more generally the Doppler effect
applies to all types of waves not just
sound waves for this reason when a
galaxy moves away from us we see it as
slightly more red and when it moves
closer to us we see it as slightly more
blue
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]